these elections are the largest test of
public opinion since the general
election and there's an awful lot at
stake firstly local elections council
elections in england scotland and wales
all seats in all local authorities in
wales and scotland will be contested if
you watch with us on the night these
will gradually get colored in as the
results come in england will remain a
little patchy although only 146 councils
in england are holding elections and
within those only half or a third of
some seats in some places are being
fought a lot of the things will be
clustered around urban areas
particularly watch london all 32 london
boroughs uh hoda holding elections for
all the councillors there now you might
ask why these local elections matter
what bearing they have on national
politics and hopefully this will help
explain this is the number of
councillors held by the different
parties over time and just have a look
at what happens ahead of changes in
government look a big tick up in
conservative councillors just before
margaret thatcher was elected a big
tick-up in labor once before blair was
elected just before cameron was elected
there as well and look the conservatives
have really dominated local politics
since then this line is a lot lower than
labour would want it to be if they want
to have success at the next general
election their task to try and tick that
line uh further up now what does a good
and bad night look like for the parties
it's really important to remember the
baseline the last time these seats was
fought was in the 2018 local elections
and you might remember labour did very
well there the conservatives not so much
so against that low baseline losses of
350 or so would be pretty catastrophic
put boris johnson under huge amounts of
pressure losses of 100 or so seats that
could be brushed off perhaps as mid-term
blues but still not great at standing
still
for the conservatives uh that would that
would be sort of okay for them
numerically not great uh but in the
current context perhaps not so bad gains
for boris johnson well that would be a
real vindication for him labor on the
other hand they're coming from a much
higher baseline so gains for kierstarma
of 200 or so seats that would be an
exceptional result it would put them
potentially on track
to win the next general election gains
of 50 or so 100 seats would also go down
pretty well now no change for labour
worth saying that might feel
disappointing given the current
conservative woes but actually it would
represent potentially winning back some
of that support that labour went on to
lose in the 2019 general election so not
too bad losses for labour that would be
big question marks for keir starman now
some of the most important and
consequential elections this time are
actually happening in northern ireland
voters they're choosing the 90
members of the northern irish assembly
each constituency all 18 of them
electing five mlas each now the voting
system is designed to very closely
reflect the vote share to the number of
seats so very unlikely that any of these
constituencies would elect five mlas
from the same party and the stakes are
very very high indeed this is what
happened last time these elections were
run in 2017 look the dup the largest
number of seats 28 but just one more
than sinn fein and at the moment sinn
fein is polling better it's polling to
be the largest party actually the dup
neck and neck in the polls at the moment
with the non-aligned alliance party if
those polls bear out and if indeed sinn
fein is the largest party that will mean
they will have the first minister's
position and it will be the first time a
nationalist party has been the largest
party in stormont it would be a hugely
significant moment in history and
potentially have big ramifications for
the union